[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
every lie tell incurs a debt to the
truth sooner or later that debt is paid
the central theme of HBO's dramatic
miniseries Chernobyl revolves around how
lies can lead to disaster how the way we
craft stories about what really happened
can cause harm this however presents an
ironic challenge when creating a
dramatization of real events dramatic
narrative by its nature requires
modification and simplification of what
actually happened
what's up so how do you tell a story
like this in a way that isn't
hypocritical step the series takes to
avoid hypocrisy is the creator's
attention to visual detail small details
about how things appeared may sometimes
seem inconsequential but the series has
an outstanding dedication to portraying
these details accurately and I think it
matters because of the nature of the
working area you will each have no more
than 90 seconds some of it is in blocks
weighing approximately 40 to 50
kilograms they all must be thrown over
the edge here what's your comrades
moving fast from this opening then
turning to the left and entering the
workspace here take care not to stumble
do you understand your mission as I have
described it
these are the most important 90 seconds
of your lives the documentary footage
I'm showing as a comparison here was
often used for reference in designing
costumes buildings sets etc most of what
is changed about the story is shifting
things on the timeline or condensing
information or characters in a way that
is necessary to tell the story and only
five episodes so you're definitely over
the whale do not look over the whale is
that clear ready go seeing the show and
reality side-by-side makes it obvious
how understated the show's approach to
the story is there would have been many
opportunities to try to make events look
and feel more dramatic but it wasn't
necessary and I think it pays off
the significance of getting visual
details like this Ray is that each
moment of the show is true to the
experience of those who were there even
when those moments might be shifted in
time or context for the sake of the
narrative one of the atomic reactors at
the Chernobyl atomic power plant in the
city of I was always aware that I was
telling a story that meant an enormous
amount to the people that lived through
it there are people alive today
thousands tens of thousands people alive
today who have lost people they love
because of Chernobyl whose lives have
been shortened because their Chernobyl
there are people walking a lot of people
walking around without a thyroid because
of Chernobyl and it was important for me
to tell that story accurately
our production designer Luke hull worked
very closely with our costume designer
Oh deal Dix Moreau we just became
obsessed with showing things as they
were
[Music]
most docudramas leave it to the viewer
to figure out what events and characters
were changed
HBO's Chernobyl interesting link gives
you the tools to learn these things the
companion podcast covers much of what
was modified and why
of those many wonderful reasons to do
this the one that was most important to
me from the jump was a chance to set the
record straight about what we do that is
very accurate to history what we do that
is a little bit sideways to it and what
we do to compress or change it's an
interesting acknowledgement by the
creators of the show of the way the meta
discussion and experience of watching a
show about true events is important to
the story and being transparent and
talking about these things and the
process of adapting reality to narrative
is commendable it sets an interesting
new standard for films and TV of this
genre truth and content ourselves
instead with stories a while ago I made
a video similar to this one
comparing the Oliver Stone movie Snowden
to actual footage from the documentary
citizen for right now on Mubi you can
watch citizen 4 and it's a great
documentary that I highly recommend go
to movie comm / Thomas flight to get
access to a free trial of movies
excellent hand curated library they have
30 films at a time every day one is
added and one is taken away and I love
that on the site you can see reviews
from other users reviews from critics
and mooby's justification for why they
chose this film it's a great way to find
new and interesting things to watch
go watch citizen 4 if you haven't for
free when you sign up for your 30-day
free trial at MU be calm / Thomas flight
that's movie calm / Thomas flight thank
you so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video special thank you to
my patrons go to patreon.com/scishow
miss flight to find out how you can get
access
two bonus videos merch a podcast a
discord channel and more